my money
[Applause]
American Sign Language interpreter
Justina miles brings the energy to
Rihanna's Super Bowl halftime show you
want to get it right you know
everybody's watching not only did we
raise pregnancy reveal viral 20 Justina
did to
coming the first
sign during the coveted spot first
making her debut during the pre-shows
lift every voice and sing performed by
Abbott Elementary star Cheryl Lee Ralph
the knees
the lift me
lift me guys
let it
ReSound to really bring that empowerment
to millions and millions of black deaf
people all over the country who've never
really seen that before
and so I they'll they should feel
inspired and that's the same way I feel
when
I feel like that is truly lifting every
voice even my voice then you can say
Justina worked her stage embracing all
of riri's hits during the Apple music
halftime show
[Applause]
[Music]
and when ree performed wild thoughts
Justina brought her dancing A-game
bye
wow
[Music]
so who is Justina well CNBC reports she
is a Philadelphia native and currently a
nursing student but the halftime show
isn't the first time she's made waves in
2020 Justine is homage to Lil Kim's 1997
song crush on you made its rounds on
Tick Tock as she signed the rapper's
iconic verses
[Music]
so let's pour it up for Justina and her
history making night
[Music]
[Applause]